what mistakes would you say you made
early on with filmmaking whether it was
with equipment you know timing whatever
the biggest mistake I ever made and it
was a inadvertent one when I first was
on set as a director I didn't spend time
with the crew and the reason I didn't
was because I didn't want them to
suspect and find out that I didn't know
much and I wasn't experienced and I was
doing this like total fish-out-of-water
like I had no clue except for what I
learned in school which but in school
you do little videos and you're not
really directing a full-on feature so
when the crew would have lunch I was
always trying to separate myself because
I didn't want to like let on that like
like Oh what have you worked on before
or you know anything question like that
I had no idea how to answer it but they
saw it as or at least my thinking I have
no idea I never asked them but I always
felt like they were a little like
standoffish because they're like oh he
doesn't want to eat with us or you know
he wants to spend time alone and I
always felt like that was it was the
wrong impression I made obviously but
again it was inadvertent cuz I was
trying to like protect myself from there
you know more investigative questions
maybe about like if I had any background
in this which I didn't so I would always
say and I still today would say you know
if you're on set and you're directing
you should spend time with your crew
because it's a true collaboration and
without all those voices coming in and
helping you to immerse yourselves in the
story
you can't think it's this like you know
I'm the only voice in this I'm the only
storyteller it's a variety of people who
are gonna help you along the way and
they all have their own voice and
creativity they're bringing to it so
that's that mutual respect across the
board that I think is super important to
make sure that you know I always keep in
the back of my mind and I know on my
next film I'll always you know really
engage more but it's so easy to get in
your own head and to kind of you know
just think and brood and
you know try to figure out how you're
gonna do a scene and you feel like
you're in and alone sometimes because
the producers are only going to you when
you're losing light and you're not
making your day but I feel now that I
need to be a little more involved with
how the crew is feeling and you know
have lunch with them and bring the
actors in on those conversations and
everyone in it together rather than you
know I think a rookie director mistake
is to think you're in it alone and that
it's you against the world in a sense
and you kind of feel like if this
doesn't go I fail which is true because
it's your name on it
and you're not if you don't make your
day and you go over-budget you could get
fired or whatnot
but I do think the voices on the crew or
super important to keep engaging and to
involve at an equal level as far as
their creativity so that's an
interesting take on perception so at
what point did it click for you that
that could have been one of the issues
and then you sort of I never cured it
okay I just did I was just that way on
that that first set and I tried to help
it on the second set but I'm a victim of
my own like thoughts when I get really
intense about how I'm gonna structure a
scene or I get you because I don't ever
plan much I always try to make decisions
on the day of and I always try to react
to what I'm given because things change
all the time if you plan too much you're
in for a rude awakening because you get
to a location and things always change
so I always try to wait until I'm there
and then when I'm there I make decisions
off-the-cuff or a little more you know
in a way that's keeping it fresh and
then I involve the actors in those
decisions in the DP etc but I would
probably try to be a little more
democratic and how I am
reacting to things and my approach
because I don't have a shot list
generally and I don't have you know a
lot of dialogue on how I'm doing certain
things so I want to make sure the next
time I communicate a little better but
as I said it's easy to get into your own
head with these things
you